we actually asked that question to a lot
of people we do this to high school
students where we call it Bill Gates for
a day we say what would you do if you
have 75 billion dollars 10 it turns out
it's very important also to say he can't
spend it on yourself but but the point
is first they think oh ok I'd solve
everything in the world and then they
realized that's actually not doable with
75 billion but the second thing that
happens is then they really want to make
sure they do the best things first
[Music]
you
[Music]
well listen I'd love to take you through
basically this set of this way that we
try to do priorities in the world and
you know as Gerry and thanks a lot for
that introduction as Gerry point out we
work with hundreds of the world's top
economists and seven Nobel laureates and
and I think we we try to set the agenda
on on talking about how to prioritize
the world the book you you got or the
book that you can get how to spend
seventy five billion it's actually a
very short version of the seven hundred
and fifty page book that we publish with
Cambridge University Press so at least
enjoy that and and and and you know
we've spent about two years preparing
this with as I said more than 100
academics but when riesen asked me and
and and wanted to hear can you take us
through all the big problems in the
world in the back I don't know 20
minutes I was like yeah sure
so so I don't know if you if you I hope
you don't mind if we're just gonna move
right into it so yeah the main point
really here is to recognize there are
lots of problems I've just listed number
more than a billion people don't have
clean drinking water pretty much
everybody would be richer if we didn't
have subsidies certainly especially
agricultural subsidies there's two civil
wars that started each year cost about
sixty billion dollars each three and a
half million this is actually wrong it's
4.2 4.3 million people now estimated
last week from the World Health
Organization die each year due to indoor
air pollution this is by far the biggest
environmental problem in the world yet
we hear almost nothing of it
it's caused by poor people almost three
billion people who cook and keep warm
with basically with dung and cardboard
and twigs and whatever they can lay
their hands on and obviously the
solution to that environmental problem
is not to environmentally certified um
but to get them out of poverty and so
the point here is to recognize you know
the 20 that I find that amazing twenty
percent of all deaths are due to easily
curable infectious diseases something we
can do at very low cost it's very very
clear that there are lots of issues out
there in the world and the question that
we try to ask is this very simple if you
had a limited amount of money let's say
75 Billy
suspend over the next four years that's
a yeah there's about 15% of the global
development budget so it's not a very
large amount of increase and although of
course seventy five billion dollars is a
significant amount of money how would
you spend that money we actually asked
that question to a lot of people we do
this to high school students where we
call Bill Gates for a day we say what
would you do if you had seventy five
billion dollars ten it turns out it's
very important also to say he can't spin
it on yourself but but the point is
first they think oh okay I'd solve
everything in the world and then they
realize that's actually not doable with
seventy five billion but the second
thing that happens is then they really
want to make sure they do the best
things first and that's really what I
want to show you and give you a little
bit of sense of how we're going to think
about this and I actually want you to
try and do a little bit same work as
what the nobles did in this in this area
so you know in reality I think the
problem here is what is it we should
focus on we tend to focus on the cute
animals the crying babies the groups
with best PR and and I would tend to say
that's probably not the best way to help
the world right it creates a state of
panic it makes us feel oh my god we got
to do something about this and that's of
course great we all want to do good but
surely we can do better and that's
really what this is about to say we
recognize that you want to do good
that's great
but shouldn't we start talking about how
you do not just feel good but do
something they'll actually do good so we
research the cost-effectiveness of
proposals and I'll show you a couple in
just a little minute and we do
prioritization but the problem with
prioritization them and I think the main
reason why so many people don't like me
or at least have this caricature of
Bjorn being this terrible person that
just put dollar signs and everything and
don't care about reality or real people
or something is that when you do
prioritization you don't just say what
should come and top you also say what we
shouldn't be doing first and that
obviously annoys the people who do this
for a living and not just because it's
their livelihood but also because they
really strongly feel this is what we
should be focused on we have a world
where
many people worry about many things
different things some people are worried
about the cute animals and the crying
babies and so on but we should ask where
do you get the biggest bang for your
buck so these are the ten challenges
that you also can find the book these
are the ten challenges that we look for
I think most people would agree yeah
these are really big issues that we're
trying to tackle in the world the sort
of natural inclination this is what
pretty much all journalists then ask me
is so which one of these problems is the
biggest problem but that question
doesn't make any sense right
I mean arguably the biggest problem in
the world is we all die right but you
know economists would say if we have a
severe under supply of immortality but
we don't quite know how to fix that
problem right so the real issue is not
to talk about what's a big problem
they're all big problems but it's about
how do you best solve it so it's about
finding solutions to these problems and
then ranking those solutions so they can
be good solutions and bad solutions to
many of these problems it actually turns
out that's pretty much all the case and
I'll try to show you some of those as
well so for armed conflict you know
maybe it's conflict prevention maybe
it's intervention we have good data that
actually indicates how much does it cost
to do a UN peacekeeping force
how much less risk is there of reversion
to a civil war for instance we do know
these numbers and so we can actually
estimate a dollar spent how much good
will that do biodiversity chronic
disease just you know one simple point I
don't know if you know tobacco tax for
instance and we estimate in the 20th
century about a hundred million people
died of tobacco but on current estimates
mainly because there's so many smokers
in China and India we are scheduled to
have about a billion people die from
tobacco so maybe we I don't know maybe
we should think about that we also
talked about heart attack pills and and
statins earlier there are lots of
different solutions to these they all
have different costs and benefits why
don't we take a look at what works and
what doesn't and try to prioritize where
can we do the most good of course it
gets a little more messy but I'll get
into some of these things later on so
basically we worked with some of the
world's top economists for instance
infectious diseases we worked with Dean
Jamison who basically
the book for World Health Organization
on the cost-effectiveness of 200 I think
they're up to 205 diseases now so they
look for instance on and they looked at
a lot of other stuff and tuberculosis
HIV and malaria but they don't just say
that'd be cool to do something about
they actually go in and say if you spend
a dollar on a specific way dealing with
tuberculosis you'll do 15 dollars worth
of good for HIV vaccine you'll do 11
dollars it was the first cost-benefit
analysis ever of HIV vaccine and malaria
does $35 worth whoo good suddenly this
becomes much less of a witch disease
have I heard most of who looks the
saddest on the pictures but much more
what can I actually do but of course you
all know if you ask academics you know
what's what's the cost and benefit you
can actually tweak these in many many
different directions so we also have two
other perspective paper authors they'll
actually come in and say yeah but this
no but that and all the other so we have
a lot of different information here and
then we present it to all our expert
panels including the up to seven Nobel
laureates they listen to all these
arguments and then they make their
prioritization across all the solutions
so basically they come out with this
prioritized list that's what I want you
to do today so I'd love to go through
all the ten challenges there's no way we
have time for that so let's just look at
two challenges
so I basically want you to prioritize
just four issues and if I could just
have a I understand that there's a
person who's in charge at each table who
have these strips you're gonna get the
same advanced technology that the Nobel
laureates use only they have magnetic
strips but you'll just have to make a
make up for that so basically what I
want you to do could you just distribute
these around the table so everyone have
one set of these strips what I want you
to do is to prioritize for solutions to
these two challenges so we're going to
look at a hunger and malnutrition and
we're gonna look at climate change yeah
I partly picked this because I think
you'd probably find this to be
interesting as well and and probably the
most interesting but I'm sure we can
also have a good conversation later on
about some of these other things I'm
going to try to keep this to about
twenty minutes and then we'll have
some 10-15 minutes for talks so let me
dwell right into it so what I want you
to do now is take this these strips and
take the top two ones so just to look at
the first two ones they're the ones that
are about malnutrition and if you could
then further subdivide them so you
basically have these two strips so it's
hard apparently to do well certainly for
me so really what I want you to do is to
decide when you've listened to the
evidence for these two solutions you
have to make up your mind do you think
they should be prioritised this way or
this way it's really just very simple
and as you can see I'm sure you imagine
sort of as we go along you'll have to
shift them more and more in and
eventually you'll have a full
prioritization so just listen to these
two proposals and find out what do you
think if you had that money where would
you spend it first if these were the
only two things that you could spend
your money on
so hunger and malnutrition clearly a
huge problem I don't think we understand
it we've just had a great dinner about a
billion people on this planet goes to
bed hungry tonight a billion people that
is not how it should be right that
numbers remain pretty constant over the
last 40 years because there are many
many more people in the planet that
means we've actually seen a significant
drop in percentage but it's still a huge
issue 18 percent of world population
this is to a very large extent because
we have dropped I don't know if you
remember the first Green Revolution back
in the 1970s when Norman Borlaug
essentially managed to feed a couple
billion people that's the cool thing to
be able to put on your CV but but you
know also the biofuel scandal I don't
know if you know but the u.s. is right
now putting so much corn into your into
your into your cars that you are
basically destroying about 5% of all
calories on the planet that's wrong and
so many different ways right I mean not
that europeís does any better we're just
not not nearly as good at producing it
but we're still trying as hard as we can
so clearly there's a huge issue here
what we're then trying to say there's
many solutions you can see all the
papers you can also go on our website
read all these papers basically we'll
look
these two solutions that you have the
R&D to increase yield enhancements and
reduce chronic undernutrition in
preschool is I just want to show you we
looked at a lot of other solutions here
crop advisory text messages for instance
to let farmers and third world countries
know when to plant what to plant when to
take it to market that kind of thing
sounds like a great idea turns out it's
not all that great but you know I love
this idea but you know the numbers speak
they're fairly clear language so I'm
just gonna look at the first two but
just realize we have looked a lot more
so I'm again showing you some of the
most interesting stuff increase
agricultural research and development
fundamentally this is the idea of
getting ever higher yields we do spend
quite a bit we've probably spent about
five billion dollars per year and we
estimate that we'll continue to do that
till about mid-century what the
economists are proposing is spend an
extra eight billion dollars a year up to
so we increase the total amount up to
thirteen billion dollars we have pretty
good models for what that would do
because we've done this in many
different areas many different places in
the world and so we estimate this would
increase growth rates for crop yields
about 0.4 percentage points so not
terribly a huge impact
but of course accumulate over almost
half a century that will have a
significant impact yeah it's not gonna
matter all that much and GDP will
increase GDP a little bit because
agriculture makes up a never small and
part of the economy it's actually not
gonna do all that much for for GDP but
it's gonna cut prices and hence it's
actually gonna decrease the number of
hungry and a business-as-usual scenario
we'll see about 200 million fewer people
starving now what are the benefits well
it's easy to calculate the cost that's
basically the eight billion dollars
discounted back from 2050 until today
you know and I'm glossing over a lot of
stuff here because we're trying to do
this in in 20 minutes but yeah in the
order of a little less than two hundred
billion dollars is the total cost over
this half century the benefits and I'm
gonna go through several iterations of
the benefits because there's actually a
number of different benefits the obvious
one is we'll get cheaper food that's
actually going to be bad for producers
but it's going to be great for consumers
there's going to be much better for
consumers and because we're all
consumers overall we're going to be much
better off so if you just count that up
simply a pure sort of consumer surplus
analysis you'll end up with about three
and a half trillion dollars and benefits
so fundamentally the point is we under
invest because there's a lot of people
who can't buy these or make sufficient
demand that the private companies will
themselves make sure that they do
produce these these products at a higher
yielding varieties so that would clearly
indicate in the order of benefit cost
ratio in the order sixteen to twenty one
so it's a great investment which of
course is also one of the reasons why
most countries most of time spend money
on making sure we have long-term
solutions to agricultural issues but
they're more to this issue I'm gonna add
three other dimensions one is it can
reduce variability obviously this is one
of the concerns who will probably also
have from global warming but also simply
we know that mostly people don't die
because they can't afford food all the
time they die because every once in a
while
food fails so we have a big drought or
we have a storm that wrecks the whole
production in an area the food prices
spike and then you die yeah it's no real
help that afterwards the food prices
come down so the reality here is if we
could reduce the variability by getting
more drought resistant or heat resistant
more saline resistant varieties which we
probably could we could actually have a
huge increase in the benefits because
many fewer people would die now the the
economists did the first estimate of the
the benefit of reduced variability
that's ever been produced they came out
with a I think too high number and
certainly the nobles didn't buy this
they probably think it's more likely in
the in the high 20s so I'm showing you
this because that's the result that's
also where you can read in the book but
I think it's probably exaggerated and
most people criticized it for being just
simply out of order is too it was too
large it has two other benefits if we
increase yields we also reduce global
warming and we benefit by
diversity why well you know
fundamentally if we if we produce more
food on the land that we already produce
food on it means that because we're
gonna be more people in the planet you
have to cut down less new forests that
means basically the forest will stand
and that helps biodiversity so
fundamentally we know that this is one
of the ways that we could make sure that
there's more biodiversity for the future
if you estimate what are people willing
to pay for this and of course there's
lots of assumptions that go into this
you probably get in the order this would
this would basically add another
trillion of dollars and benefits if you
then also estimate how much benefit
would this do because we keep the trees
standing you'll actually keep the carbon
locked up in those forests and that
means you'll have less greenhouse gases
so that will probably also add another
trillion dollars or so the total benefit
if you also assume the lower one on
variability is in the order of thirty to
forty dollars worth of good now
obviously if we had much longer time we
could then have a nice methodological
discussion about do we believe these
numbers do we believe this estimate do
we believe that this is possible do we
have good evidence that in case is it
just gonna go into a huge big hole in
government funding and all these kinds
of conversations but given we don't I'm
sorry we'll just have to sort of say
yeah this is probably not totally off
but the beautiful thing is this makes it
much much more likely that when you sit
and discuss and just as you will in just
a little bit of time with a person next
to you
you sit and discuss which one of these
should be on top you'll suddenly be
using a very different vocabulary this
is probably not so true here at the
reason our conversation but you'd be
amazed when you do this we've done this
with youth politicians with high school
students with politicians with bankers
pretty much anyone any any kind of group
and the amazing thing is it really
changes the way you talk even you know
very left-leaning politicians start
talking about efficiency and where do
you get the biggest bang for your buck
it changes the way you think about these
conversations and that I think is the
ultimately best outcome because it
pushes people towards being smarter so
let's assume at least for now that this
is probably in the order
3240 simply because we'll make sure that
we get more food to more people cheaper
and that is actually both good for
people but it's also good for
environment and it's good for
biodiversity the second one is a much
more sort of straightforward this first
one was very much sort of research into
the future will make it better the other
one is simply get food to small kids
there's there's about a hundred million
kids that will grow up being in one way
or another
more or less stunted we can do something
about that it's just simply about
getting food to them it's not a yeah
it's not rocket science we had the food
we know how to do we also pretty much
know what the cost is this is the
estimate if we actually do this just for
one kid over the first thousand days
very very simple and cheap the total
cost is about $96 per kid that feels
like mmm we should probably do that
that'd be a nice thing to do
but it actually is much more than just a
nice thing to do because again we don't
just say this would be good we ask how
much will it cost that's $96 at the kid
but also how much good would it do well
the cost is simple to do if you do but
31 million kids a year
it'll cost three billion dollars a year
and those are probably the most
vulnerable kids that we're talking about
that we would reach so we'd reach every
year we get a new generation of 31
million kids so it would be about about
one fifth of the total population of
kids that are being born each year so we
really make a huge difference but the
but the real question of course is what
would be the benefits it actually turns
out and we've been trying to sell this
to 60 minutes and and you know I think
it's a wonderful story and it's a story
that's not been told we've been arguing
for a very long time for unthreat achill
ground so this is a phenomenal impact
now I'll tell you why in just a second
but last year we actually managed to
publish a study from Guatemala which
very very clearly demonstrates why this
is a great idea it's actually such that
back in the late 1960s some American
researchers went to Guatemala they found
two small villages and they gave the
kids in those villages good food then
they found two other villages next
they were identical in all aspects now
you can kind of hear with this gang and
they gave those kids bad food you know
it's the 60s you could get away with
that but the amazing thing is they've
now come back and refined all of these
kits we found about almost 80% of them
so 3500 kids they're now in their late
30s early 40s and you can see the
difference the only difference is one
set of kids got good food the other kids
out of kids didn't and the difference is
amazing and pretty much all accounts so
their brains develop more their muscles
develop more they stayed longer in
school they learn more in school their
marriages are better they have better
they're better jobs they have fewer kids
if they're women they're fewer
miscarriages but by far the most
important thing if you're an economist
at least is when you measure how much of
a difference did this make to your
income it turns out that if you avoid it
being stunted so basically a measure of
being really malnourished which of
course not everybody did but if you
avoid it being stunted you would end up
being three times richer you just simply
be much much more productive your pay
per year would be about three times
higher so the stunning would result in
the sixty-six percent wage reduction we
estimate that 36 percent the kids would
be avoided stunted if we fed them well
so fundamentally we can make many more
kids much more productive into their
adult lives we can basically make sure
that even though they go to really
crappy schools which much probably many
of them will do they will learn more
they will be smarter they'll be stronger
they'll be more productive and when they
come out in real life afterwards they
will make much much more money they will
start a virtuous circle though mean that
they will end up making a much better
society for their kids and of course a
much better family for their kids
they'll also be a healthier we know that
their kids are healthier and it will go
on in that virtuous circle if you do the
math if you just simply add up what's
the benefits of this extra consumption
basically the extra income from from the
pay it turns out that the benefit cost
ratio is 59 so for every dollar spent
you will do 59 dollars worth of good
this is
not just based in Guatemala this is base
we have other studies that are not
nearly as long but it's the most
exciting study that we have we have from
Bangladesh and from a number of African
countries so the fundamental point here
is to say this is real-world studies
this is taking into account the fact
that some of this money will go to
corruption somehow it won't get to the
kids some of them won't get what they
need it and all that stuff but even
given that we can do an amazing amount
of good and of course remember this is
just a benefit from schooling in the
sense of future income we don't talk
about the fact that this would also
actually help them I don't know it's
nice not to be stunted it's nice not to
starve and that's also part of it but we
don't actually evaluate that now my
point here is simply to say we are
providing part of this conversation
we're providing the price tags if you
will to these opportunities this is not
the only thing you want to know but if
you think about it it's a little bit
like going into a really fancy
restaurant and getting a menu and there
are no prices unless you're you're
really on a good expense account that'll
make you somewhat uncomfortable right
what would your gonna order what are you
gonna end up paying we put the price
tags on we put the calorie content how
much how big these these plates are and
all that stuff it doesn't mean you pick
the cheapest but it means you now know
what you're picking and what you're
getting so essentially this is the price
list this is the way that we have the
opportunity of seeing how much good do
you do for each dollar but you can
decide and you can have arguments for
why some of these things are undervalued
some of them are under overvalued why
you think some of them have more ethical
value and you're gonna therefore decide
on one or the other but that's exactly
what I want you to do if I could ask you
for the next 30 seconds and sorry again
just 30 seconds talk to the person next
to you and convince them why they are
phenomenally wrong and why they should
do this instead of the other way around
so could you just discuss and decide for
yourself at least how are you gonna
prioritize these two all right
guys I know this is in some way this is
just unreasonable right but I I hope
that you have now decided if you were
actually gonna spend money where you
gonna spend it on on a Nutrition to
small kids or are you gonna spend it on
yield increases but now of course
nutrition that's not the only issue
hunger is not the only issue yeah and
ideally we'd have gone through all ten
of these issues and started talking
about well how would you prioritize all
these I'm just gonna show you one other
things so you have the other two ones
that are for global warming so if you
could risk those apart and basically
your decision is where do they fit in do
they both go up on top both go down the
bottom just one of them you know come in
in the middle so you have to decide
where would you now spend this extra
money so let me just very briefly on
global warming
yes global rings are a problem it's a
there will be a significant temperature
increase in the long run I'm just
showing you some of these risks that
people are talking a lot about I think
perhaps it's important to emphasize two
things that most people don't talk about
when they talk about global warming that
the negative effects that we expect from
global warming will first come in the
second half of the century overall you
know overall global warming is probably
good for mid latitude and high latitude
countries and it's bad for low latitude
countries essentially where it's already
pretty damn warm it's not a good idea it
gets warmer if you live in Denmark more
warmth is perhaps not so bad
and the second thing is nothing you do
matters before the second half of the
century even if we dramatically cut
carbon emissions it would have virtually
no effect before the second half of the
century or as New York Times put it if
we do everything el gore says or if we
just have a carbon fest the next couple
of decades you won't be able to measure
the difference before mid century so
it's important to recognize this is only
a long-term issue so remember yes there
are real problems but we often forget
that this is not about you know putting
up lots of solar panels now and and and
doing something tomorrow it's about
putting up lots of solar panels and
you'll see a very small change in a
hundred years so there's lots of
solutions again and you can see we
actually have
a lot of different papers on it because
it's a lot of different disciplines you
get in I'm just gonna look at two things
one is the solution that everybody
signed up to a carbon tax they will
which we expect is probably the most
effective way of cutting carbon
emissions that will limit the
temperature rise to two degrees
centigrade or 3.6 degrees Fahrenheit you
already know this is artificial limit
when it's sort of an even number rate
but it just turns out that way
and the second one is to make green
energy cheaper through innovations so
the Rd solution as you can see there's
lots and lots of other solutions I love
to talk more about them but again I just
want it to get for solutions in here
so the two-degree lumen we know we can
do it or actually it's kind of hard to
do it but obviously we can just make an
arbitrarily large carbon tax in them we
can cut as much co2 as we want it turns
out that actually if you look at the
Stanford energy modeling forum which has
all the energy models that we run that's
typically considered the gold standard
it's what everybody uses the World Bank
the International Energy Agency the EU
well that you only use the cheap ones
but but you know fundamentally the idea
here is to say if you run them half of
the model say we can't do it so we're
already running on the optimistic set of
models and they basically say sure you
can but it's gonna cost you a very very
large amount of money it's gonna be I
mean a $68 ton of carbon tax for the
world so that's also China and India of
course there's some political issues
with that and racing to four thousand
dollars per ton by the end of the
century just to give you a sense of
impact that means sixty cents on the
gallon now and about twenty-five dollars
per gallon of gasoline in 2100 that's
not a trivial amount I think yeah that'd
probably be hard to get through in the
US I'm guessing and and it would be
almost fantasy to imagine getting this
anywhere else there's actually a lot of
countries that wouldn't be able to
afford this over their GDP right so so
it's it's a bite by all means of an
exceptionally hard target every bit all
leaders political leaders including
Obama and Merkel and everybody else have
signed up to this but of course it
doesn't actually mean they they are
going to do it but this would be
probably the cheapest way to do it it
would reduce temperatures from about
three and a half degrees centigrade to
two degrees that's by definition it
would achieve that it would be
phenomenally expensive the models and
this is the average of all the
macroeconomic models indicate that the
cost would be about 40 trillion dollars
per year by by the end of the century
there'll be about 13 percent of global
GDP that's actually in line with what it
seems like the UN climate panel is going
to come out with on Monday so you know
it's it's very much in the ballpark or
what everybody comes up with there would
also be benefits we would have reduced
the worst of global warming but of
course it would not be in the same order
of magnitude it'd probably be about two
trillion dollars and remember the
benefits would come much further out
whereas we start paying very soon and
that's why the total benefit cost ratio
works out to about two cents per dollar
so for every dollar you spend you'll
avoid about two cents of climate damage
now that's not zero but it's it's not
terribly good you could yeah you could
obviously have done 98 cents more good
if you just given people the dollar so
it's it's it's it's it's not a
particularly good solution right but you
know it's there because this is actually
the one that we talked about obviously
if you had much much lower carbon taxes
you could actually get one that was
above one you could get one that gives
you one and a half dollars back on the
dollar which is of course why most
economists would say if co2 is a problem
you should tax it the marginal cost
which is probably about five dollars per
ton per ton so if you could get global
five dollar carbon tax and offset it on
other taxes you could probably actually
end up with a small positive but it's
very very hard to get above a small
positive or a small benefit cost ratio a
little above one so this gives you about
two cents back on the dollar but there's
another solution basically increase
dramatically Green Energy Research and
Development essentially make the next
generations of green energy much much
cheaper if you do that you will
essentially fix global warming long long
run because you will make possible
solutions that will eventually be
marketable that will make everyone want
to switch so China and India everybody
else will switch not because they're
forced to by Kyoto Stalin treaty
but simply because green energy is so
cheap peripherally cheaper than fossil
fuel that everybody will switch and you
know we've seen that certainly in a
small kind of way and and in the u.s.
you have for entirely different reasons
you the DoD probably spent about ten
billion dollars and subsidizing the
early fracking results and fracking now
of course has made gas so cheap in the
u.s. that you have cut about three
hundred megatons of co2 per year in the
u.s. of course that was not at all your
intention you just realize there was
really cheap and so you switch from coal
to gas and and since gas emits about
half the amount of co2 per energy unit
produced you've actually cut about these
three hundred megatons and compared this
to the fact that all the world's wind
and solar cuts about two hundred and
seventy-five megatons so you've actually
sort of inadvertently ended up cutting
more co2 than all the world's wind and
solar together every year and you've
done so because you've made gas cheaper
so where it's the rest of the world and
you also are paying about sixty billion
dollars for solar and wind you are
making about a hundred billion dollars
on fracking and yeah the simple point is
it's a lot easy to convince everybody
would you rather cut more co2 oh and
make a lot of money then pay a lot of
money and cut less and that's why if we
could make this happen and not just for
fracking obviously if we get China
fracking we'd probably do a lot better
but of course in the long run we also
need to move away from gas so if we
could eventually get real green
solutions to be so cheap that everybody
wanted them that would actually be a
phenomenal impact so they estimate we'd
need to spend about a hundred billion
dollars per year in the long run
remember right now the world probably
spends about 200 billion dollars and in
global warming policy so it still be
cheaper but you know it's not an
insubstantial amount of money but we
actually estimate that the benefit cost
ratio obviously that's a huge discussion
on exactly how do you do that and
long-term development technology but
it's in the order of magnitude of eleven
dollars back so for every dollar spent
you'll avoid about eleven dollars of
climate damage so the reality here is
again as I also tried to point out it's
not that there's one problem and it's
either a good problem or bad
you can have really bad policies and you
can have pretty good policies for both
of these areas and so the real issue
here is to say well what would you want
to choose and if you put this question
to people even very left-wing people
I've done this you know they will sit
and say well you know I like global
warming and I think it's a huge problem
so I'll move both of my strips a little
up and and some of you and here will
probably move it a little down that's
fine but you sort of you're informed by
the rationality of the conversation of
saying where do you get the biggest bang
for your buck and that I think is the
real trick that we actually end up doing
much much smarter so if I could ask you
to then just have that conversation with
a person next to you how are you gonna
mesh all these four in there and then
we're just very quickly gonna do a
survey and then we'll have a result from
the room yeah I would again if if we'd
had a lot more time we'd have we'd have
had a lot of really interesting
conversations about how do we believe
these models work we would have had a
lot more things that we were to talk
about one of the things I'd love to talk
about is education policy because
everybody loves talking about education
turns out we have very very poor
education solutions so again my sense is
maybe we should fix something we know
how to fix rather than fix stuff we
don't know how to fix there are lots of
other things but you know you've just
prioritized four issues and I'm just
simply gonna do a very very brief survey
I'm just gonna ask you to vote for your
top solution so I'm not even gonna talk
about the the two top ones normally when
we have the no bus and we have much more
time we take the meeting of all the
rankings of the different impacts I just
want to get to see a show of hands so we
get a sense of what does the room think
so if I could ask you who votes for the
Rd to increase yield enhancements just
raise your hand if that's your top
priority
Wow there so Hugh is there is there an
issue here in the room it seems like all
the agricultural people over here
alright the reduced chronic
undernutrition and small children
alright that looks like the winner who's
going to go for a high Globo carbon tax
there's usually one or two people who
feel sort of slightly intimidated and go
yeah and that's that's great that you
guys are zero and increased green Rd
there you have it the point here yeah
and I think it's very obvious that we
all picked the chronic undernutrition
and it probably also reasonable to
assume that this room actually came out
pretty much in according with the
ranking of what the economists would do
that's not very surprising and sense
because we don't have all that much
other information but the beauty of this
I think is really that it allows us to
have a conversation that suddenly makes
it legitimate to ask what is the bang
for the buck if you look in your book
you can actually see the nobles ranked
about 40 different proposals and they
came up with arguments for why the some
of these things are phenomenal why some
of them are not so phenomenal and why we
definitely shouldn't do some of them and
the amazing thing is this really impacts
influences a lot of conversations
obviously the fact that climate comes in
the bottom pisses off people who do
climate but likewise the people who do
nutrition love us again not surprisingly
but the World Bank has changed their
their their their position on nutrition
a lot of development agencies are now
giving a lot more money to nutrition and
actually just last year the last year
Britain managed to get donations for
about twelve billion dollars mostly
argued on the background of coab Megan
consensus and that's of course wonderful
because essentially this pushes a to do
better we don't do well there's still
lots of stuff that we waste money on but
if we can push the conversation towards
smarter decisions I think we've done a
good job so could I ask you what what
are your questions so let's open up for
questions and let's get some some
conversation going yeah
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you